hey guys we're the cast of Cobra Kai
here today is wired correspondence
it's reviewing martial arts gadgets
[Music]
all right let's bring on the first
Gadget
it kind of looks like some sort of like
breathing apparatus it's quite a bit
more top-heavy than I would have
imagined oh
hey Johnny with it real quick yeah I'm
asking about it I will not because it
feels like it's like 15 pounds the Chuck
Fit Chopper is designed to serve as an
all-in-one revolutionary piece of
Fitness technology a total full body as
opposed to a not total full body
challenge that never gets stale if you
want home gym equipment this is the
end-all be-all
lumberjack
brings amazing
amazing Ellen De weird five stars total
waste of money this is the kind of
techno junk that makes people sour on
training don't be taken in by something
because it has Johnny whiz-bang
technology connected to your phone J Bar
one star Johnny whizbang this just looks
like
that looks like bo staff it's like you
know it's the same thing yeah go
three times three
four I hate you all you got this don't
give up
don't give up
give me a good baby
I'm gonna rip these pants
these are rentals
oh
what
one
two
three everything
four three what
no
one
two oh she's got four oh my God what the
heck I didn't know chopping could be
done so flawlessly we need you out there
is it good I actually really like it
really I do my arm is sore my arm hurts
I wish you could hit the ground more
with it yeah I thought there was going
to be a sensor in it yeah right yeah
they should have like a little pad thing
maybe you could do that I mean it's cool
they need like a Just Dance equivalent
I'll give it three stars I mean I
haven't been a lumberjack for 40 plus
years so I don't I can't speak to
experience but it's yeah it's good
foreign
the magic pocket staff is a hollow thin
tube made of high quality stainless
steel and it can only be used as a
professional magic prop please wear
gloves it is recommended that you wear
gloves to play recommended is bolded
this thing is terrifying okay that's
great it popped out of the package as
soon as I opened it and almost took out
my friend's eyes
we'll be suing for the Brews on my foot
an emotional trauma five stars by
Samantha that's the positive review I
don't understand do not buy I repeat do
not buy ever and when I open the box to
get it out it smacked me in the mouth
and it just broke immediately Robert one
star
you got it man
you got it
[Music]
[Applause]
um
oh [ __ ] oh I broke it already what the
heck
this thing does suck
oh
yeah it seems like one of those like
secret weapons I'm getting robbed not
today
it snapped on the end it's not gonna do
anything
to fight a little kid pretty good but to
like any practical use this is a zero
the next device
[Music]
yeah I don't like this thing it's a
torture device yeah actually yes
achieve full splits fast easy to use
allows you to spread your legs as far as
possible oh uh and stretch your
hamstrings without requiring help from a
partner you were worried about splitting
your pants before no everyone gets a
show I use it almost every night while
watching TV and after my workouts while
my legs are still warmed up I've been
using it for the past month and can see
the progress so far Melissa and she
gives it five stars oh my God Melissa I
hate you I hate you with all my heart
kiss poor very flimsy and cheats in my
closet and I am too embarrassed to
actually give it to someone else Jayvon
says that one star you should be
embarrassed
I was just think I really like it but
maybe it's because people in stunts on
COBRA Kai own them and they have them in
their duffel bag and so I just now think
it's cool I wanted my duffel bag I don't
want to use it I feel like it's
overpriced it's like 50 bucks it's 24
dollars
all right
he looks so
don't think you have to have it next
Gadget
it's a baby baguette tell us Johnny oh
squishy that's squishier than I think
strength trainer thing it vibrates oh
okay
I really think I'm all right improve
your grip strength and Carry Out
day-to-day tasks seamlessly is a modern
take on classic stress balls fight off
daily stresses and anxieties all while
improving your hand grip this product is
useful for everyone who wants to
strengthen their hands and wrist muscles
while working out at the desk love the
product so much we'll give to my husband
and my friends at work thank Jay star
star star star like she's giving it to
her husband
save your money buy a rubber ball it is
totally ridiculous Mr Bill one star you
have it in your right hand yeah all
right squeeze oh whoa 80 pounds of force
just like Mr Bill okay ready it's gonna
go up when she
84. 84. all right are you ready okay I'm
ready okay
oh
there's games let's do um balloon
Blaster squeeze to shoot balloons the
harder you squeeze the more damage your
balloon does
grip to start the game die die
no
no no what oh I read it
oh no it's been a kid to me Johnny
Johnny
it's gonna get to me oh [ __ ] oh there we
go I'm trying
foreign
three stars for fun
in terms of actual grip strength
training I think realistically it's like
not any better or worse than anything
else I mean yeah it's probably more
entertaining yeah yeah what is the price
on it
that's not bad is the app free see it's
a 50 app
just hurts your hand bring on the next
Gadget
oh this is used
oh
Wing Chun it's like the does it move I
thought they were supposed to move the
Augusta Pro Wing Chun Jong arms can be
adjusted to almost leveled or staggered
positions most affordable professionally
made most durable Wing Chun dummy ever
let's see how durable this thing is the
iron body drawing is great better than
expected this thing is nice I expected
cheap finish but got luxury Luke Wales
purchase a wooden model two unstable and
the main body is made of metal pipe
makes a lot of noise one star learn it
and do it have you guys have seen it man
I've heard of it bro it's it's so cool
oh wow all right Jacob you got it I feel
like I'm gonna hit myself I hope so
maybe if there was a choreo sequence
that we had to learn we could just place
this there and then practice the moves
on it slowly I really struggle with
releasing my hook kicks too early but my
stunt double has adapted to putting
boxes in my way to like force me to wait
to do it so in that way I would just use
it as a big old post this is like a lot
cheaper than the wooden ones I could see
a reason for getting this uh this
thing's probably like 170 bucks yeah 200
bucks
[Music]
399 you could probably pay someone on
Craigslist to do the same thing
I would give it three two I said two
yeah that's me and Johnny I'm a mean guy
I feel like some of them were were fun
and like techy and that's fun but I just
don't I think the majority of these I
would I wouldn't personally use other
than the stretcher all right guys that's
it that's all five of our martial arts
gadgets wired correspondents out
maybe we'll see you guys for a part
three what do you guys think yeah
perhaps perhaps
[Music]